SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN, I WRITE A GULL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER. BLAKESPEAR
BRADFORD. CABALLERO CORTESI.
DALLY. DODD. THE RAZO. EGM.
GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES. LAYERED LEMON.
MAGUIRE. MENJIVAR MIN. NEWMAN.
WHEN. NILO OCHO BADIL. FORINO.
RIGHT? RUBIO. THEY ARE TO
DINNER. SMALL CUEVAS STERN.
HUMBERG WELL. WEINER. WELL.
MEMBERS OF QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS.
ON THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY,
PLEASE RISE. WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY OUR
CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELLE CORMAN
, AFTER WHICH WE'RE GONNA ASK
YOU TO REMAIN STANDING AND WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. WE GATHER IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. ON OCTOBER 19TH 1796
IN HIS FAREWELL ADDRESS. GEORGE
WASHINGTON SAID THE FOLLOWING.
THIS WILL BE WORTHY OF A FREE
AND ENLIGHTENED AND GREAT
NATION. TO GIVE TO MANKIND. THE
MAGNANIMOUS EXAMPLE. OF A PEOPLE
ALWAYS GUIDED BY AN EXALTED
JUSTICE AND BENEVOLENCE.
GRACIOUS GOD AND GOD OF OUR
ANCESTORS. WE PRAY TODAY AND
THANKSGIVING FOR THE LEADERSHIP
OF OUR PRESIDENTS GEORGE
WASHINGTON AND ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
IN TIMES OF GREAT UPHEAVAL. THEY
LAID FOUNDATIONS OF LIBERTY AND
DEMOCRACY. FOR THE BENEFIT OF
FUTURE GENERATIONS. TODAY WE ARE
STILL LEANING INTO THE MEANING
OF LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
AS THE LEGISLATORS OF OUR TIME
STRIVE TO BE GUIDED BY THE IDEAL
OF EXALTED JUSTICE. GRACIOUS
GOD. WITH THE LEGISLATORS IN
THIS CHAMBER. AS THEY PURSUE THE
DREAM OF PEACE AND HARMONY. AMID
THE DETAILS AND DECISIONS OF THE
MOMENT. MAY THEIR CONSTITUENTS
ALSO. EMBRACE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF DEMOCRACY.
SO THAT TOGETHER WE CAN BUILD A
JUST AND PRODUCTIVE SOCIETY.
FULFILLING THE DESIRES SET FORTH
BY THE FOUNDERS OF OUR COUNTRY.
WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME. AMEN.
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
AMERICA.
ALL MEMBERS WERE MOVING THE
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THAT
WILL BE DEAN RED. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY. WE DEEM RED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION OF BILLS AND FIRST
READING BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
RED. CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. WE HAVE TWO ITEMS WE HAVE
ITEM 12 AND 21. SENATORS, ARE
YOU PREPARED?
SENATOR ALVARADO. GAIL, ARE YOU
PREPARED? SECRETARY. PLEASE READ
. DIDN'T CONC RESOLUTION 99 BY
SENATOR ALVARADO GILL RELATIVE
TO CALIFORNIA ALMOND DAY.
SENATOR ALVARADO. GAIL THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 99 NAMING FEBRUARY
16TH AS CALIFORNIA ALMOND DAY.
ALMONDS ARE A CORNERSTONE CROP
IN CALIFORNIA, ACCOUNTING FOR
100% OF THE NATION'S ALMOND
SUPPLY AND 80% OF THE GLOBAL
ALMOND SUPPLY. PACKED WITH PLANT
BASED GOODNESS. CALIFORNIA
ALMONDS ARE RESPONSIBLY GROWN
ZERO WASTE FARM, UH, FOOD
PRODUCT AND IMPORTANT PART OF
THE LOW CARBON DIET. SUSTAINABLE
ALMOND FARMING UTILIZES
PRODUCTION PRACTICES THAT ARE
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE AND BASED
UPON SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH, COMMON
SENSE AND A RESPECT FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT, NEIGHBORS AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES. THE RESULT IS
PLENTIFUL, HEALTHY AND A SAFE
FOOD PRODUCT. THE ALMOND
INDUSTRY EMPLOYS 100 AND 10,000
CALIFORNIANS AND CONTRIBUTES 9.2
BILLION ANNUALLY TO OUR ECONOMY.
THE AUBURN INDUSTRY ALSO EMPLOYS
CALIFORNIANS. CALIFORNIANS ON
7600 ALMOND FARMS, 90% OF WHICH
ARE FAMILY FARMS, MANY OWNED AND
OPERATED BY 3RD AND 4TH
GENERATION FARMERS WHO LIVE ON
THE LAND AND PLAN TO PASS IT
DOWN TO THEIR CHILDREN.
CALIFORNIA ALMOND FARMERS AND
PROCESSORS ARE LEADING BY
EXAMPLE AND PAVING THE WAY FOR
IMPROVEMENTS ACROSS AGRICULTURE
AND A HEALTHIER PLANET.
CALIFORNIA ALMOND FARMERS ARE
COMMITTED TO FURTHER REDUCING
WATER USE TO GROW OUR ALMONDS.
BY 2025. THE CALIFORNIA ALMOND
COMMUNITY COMMITS TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF WATER USED TO GROW A
POUND OF ALMONDS BY AN
ADDITIONAL 20% ALREADY ACHIEVING
GREAT REDUCTIONS OF OVER 30. THE
CALIFORNIA ALMOND. UM, THE
CALIFORNIA ALMOND COMMUNITY ALSO
COMMITS TO ACHIEVE ZERO WASTE IN
OUR ORCHARDS BY PUTTING
EVERYTHING WE GROW TO OPTIMAL
USE. CALIFORNIA ALMOND FARMERS
ARE ACHIEVING ZERO WASTE IN OUR
ORCHARDS. THE NUTRITIOUS ALMONDS
THAT WE EAT, GROW IN A SHELL
PROTECTED BY A HULL AND TREE,
ALL PRODUCTS THAT ARE
TRADITIONALLY USED FOR LIVESTOCK
BETTING AND DAIRY FEED. WITH
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURAL
PRACTICES LIKE REGENERATIVE
FARMING, FURTHER PRODUCTION
IMPROVEMENTS AND POLICY CHANGES.
ALMOND FARMS CAN BE CARBON
NEUTRAL OR EVEN CARBON NEGATIVE.
TODAY WE CELEBRATE THOSE ALMOND
GROWERS, FARM WORKERS AND
PROCESSORS AND OTHER INDUSTRY
PARTNERS AND MANUFACTURING AND
TRANSPORTATION. CALIFORNIANS WE
HONOR WE HONOR YOU WITH TODAY'S
RESOLUTION. SOME OF THE GROWERS
OF CALIFORNIA ARE HERE IN THE
GALLERY FROM EVANS FARMS AND
FROM VAN FAMILY FARMS.
CONSTITUENTS OF SENATE DISTRICTS
, ONE FROM THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
BIEBER AND SENATE-DISTRICT,
EIGHT FROM THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
SACRAMENTO. AND I CANNOT
CELEBRATE ALMOND GROWERS WITHOUT
THE HONEY BEES BECAUSE HONEY,
BEES AND ALMONDS ARE A BEAUTIFUL
PARTNERSHIP DESIGNED BY NATURE.
I WOULD SAY THE PERFECT
MARRIAGE. WHEN ALL MEN TREES
BLOSSOM, HONEY BEES GET THEIR
FIRST NUTRITIONAL FOOD SOURCE OF
THE YEAR AND THEY POLLINATE AND
THEY THRIVE. SO PLEASE JOIN ME
IN CELEBRATING CALIFORNIA ALMOND
DAY AND AS A TOKEN OF
SENATE-DISTRICT FOR LOVE, PLEASE
ENJOY A SNACK BAG OF ANY ONE OF
MY FAVORITE BLUE DIAMOND ALMOND
FLAVORS AVAILABLE FOR YOU AFTER
SESSION. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR DALLAS. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I TOO
RISE ON THIS, UH, RESOLUTION,
UH, ACKNOWLEDGING AMMON'S OR
ALMONDS DEPENDS ON WHAT PART OF
THE STATE YOU'RE FROM. UH, MY
PART OF THE STATE WE SAY AMMONS
AND IN THE SOUTH PART OF THE
STATE SEEMS TO SAY ALMONDS, BUT,
UH, I WILL JUST WANT TO SHARE AS
A FARMER, UH, OF THE OBVIOUSLY,
ALMONDS ARE A HUGE CROP IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'VE SUPPLY THE
WORLD. UH AND, UH, 100% OF
AMERICA'S AMMONS COME FROM
CALIFORNIA. AND SO I JUST WANTED
TO, UH, STAY AND RISE IN
SOLIDARITY WITH MY GOOD FRIEND,
UH, FROM THE FOURTH
SENATE-DISTRICT IN RECOGNIZING
THAT ALMONDS 80% OF YUBA COUNTY
AND 90% AND SUTTER WHICH ARE IN
MY DISTRICT, UH, THEIR COUNTIES
PRODUCE, UH, A HECK OF A LOT OF
ALMONDS, AND, UM THERE'S SOME
CONTROVERSY OUT THERE ABOUT
THIS, THOUGH, WHEN IT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT WATER AND THE
ENVIRONMENT, AND I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT, UM UH, NOT DON'T
LISTEN TO ALL THE PEOPLE ON THE
OTHER SIDE. THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT WATER. THERE'S GOOD REASON
TO HAVE, UH, FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
AND FOR THE SOIL AND FOR, UM,
FOOD PRODUCTION AND A GOOD
PROTEIN THAT IS HEART HEALTHY
AND A VERY GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA.
SO UH, TO GET THE FAX FARMERS
ARE GREAT. WE NEED TO EAT EVERY
DAY. AND UH, WE NEED THEM HERE
IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALSO A BIG PART OF OUR ECONOMY.
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ASHBY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
JACKSON. SHE DOES SUCH A NICE
JOB WITH HER PRESENTATIONS. UH,
I. I LIKE ALMOND DAY BECAUSE I
LIKE TO USE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
AN AMAZING PLACE CALIFORNIA IS,
AS WE STAND HERE IN OUR STATE
CAPITOL IN SACRAMENTO, ONE OF
THE LARGEST CITIES IN CALIFORNIA
. WE'RE ALSO JUST A FEW BLOCKS
AWAY FROM THE LARGEST ALMOND
DISTRIBUTOR IN THE WHOLE
COUNTRY. BLUE DIAMOND SACRAMENTO
IS SO PROUD. TO HOUSE BLUE
DIAMOND. AND UH, TODAY IS A DAY
TO CELEBRATE. ALL THAT IS
AGRICULTURAL AND ALL THAT IS
AMAZING ABOUT OUR GREAT STATE.
SO I URGE AND I VOTE AND, UH,
THANK MY COLLEAGUE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR EDMOND. UH, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MR PRESIDENT. I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION. I. I SHARE THE
DISTRICT WITH THE SENATOR. UH,
FROM THE FOURTH DISTRICT. I
STILL REPRESENT, UH, HALF OF
STANISLAW COUNTY. UH, AND HAVING
GROWN UP IN STANISLAW COUNTY ON
AN ALMOND ORCHARD AS THE
DAUGHTER OF A BEEKEEPER, I FEEL
SPECIAL PASSION ABOUT THIS
RESOLUTION. UH, YOU CAN'T HAVE
ALMONDS WITHOUT THE BEES AND
I'LL ALSO SAY THAT CURRENTLY
LESS THAN A QUARTER OF
CALIFORNIA BEES ARE ABLE TO
POLLINATE THE AMOUNT OF ALMONDS
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA NOW
AND SO WHEN YOU SEE UH, TRUCKS.
YOU'LL SEE THEM GOING AROUND
WITH THOSE BIG BOXES. THEY ARE
SHIPPING THEM IN FROM MONTANA,
MISSOURI, MICHIGAN ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY. AND JUST THIS MORNING,
THERE WAS AN ARTICLE IN THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES THAT THERE WAS
ANOTHER 1000 BE SOLD OUT OF A
FARM IN FRESNO COUNTY, AND THAT
FARMER IS OFFERING $100,000 FOR
THE RETURN OF THOSE BEES OR TO
FIND OUT WHO TOOK THEM. SO AS WE
CELEBRATE ALMONDS, WE ALSO HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT THOSE BEES AND
THAT WORKFORCE THAT ALSO
TRANSPORTS THEM AND TRIES TO, UH
, MAKE SURE THE BEES STAY STRONG
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T HAVE THE BEE
STAYING STRONG WELL, WE WON'T
HAVE THOSE ALMONDS AND THE
BLOOMS THAT GO ALONG WITH IT. SO
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR S¼ R
99. THANK YOU, SENATOR MANAR.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT,
COLLEAGUES I SENT TODAY AS AN
ALLY OF A SUPPORTER OF ALMOND
DAYS BECAUSE I'M ALLERGIC
TORMENTS. I STAND IN. SO I STAND
REPRESENTING THE MANY PEOPLE
ALLERGIC TO PEANUTS AND ALMONDS,
STRONG AE URGING EVERYONE TO
VOTE I ON S¼ èC R 99. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. NÓ SENATOR
ALVARADO. GAIL, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
MY COLLEAGUES AND TO OUR ALLIES.
I URGE AND I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 12. ALAN HØI. I'LL
ROLL TO YOU. AYE. A LOT OF I
ASHBY. I ATKINS I BECKER AYE,
BLAKESPEAR. BRADFORD AY
CABALLERO UH, CORTESI. AYE,
DALLY. AYE, DODD. AYE, TORAZO. I
EGM. GLASER. AYE. GONZALES. AYE,
GROVE. HER DAD. HØI JONES. I
LAIRD. AYE, LIMÓN. HØI MCGUIRE.
AYE, MENJIVAR. AYE, MEN. HØI
NEWMAN. I WIN. AYE, NILO. A èC
ABOUT AYE PADILLA PORTANTINO.
ROTH. HØI RUBIO. I SAY ARTO, AYE
SKINNER. HIY SMALL CUEVAS. I.
HUMBERG AYE, WE HAVE AYE,
WIENER. WELL. AYE. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BLAKESPEAR.
ADMIN. HØI GROWTH. NILO. BUT
TORTINO STERN. WEINER. I. 30
THREE KNOWS ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 3121. SENATOR
RUBIO. SHE'S PREPARED SECRETARY
MAY REID. SENATE RESOLUTION 60
THREE BY SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE
TO TEEN DATING, VIOLENCE,
AWARENESS AND PREVENTION MONTH.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT AND SENATE COLLEAGUES.
TODAY I RISE TO INTRODUCE SENATE
RESOLUTION 63, WHICH PROCLAIMED
FEBRUARY 2024 TEEN DATING,
VIOLENCE, AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION MONTH. I WOULD FIRST
LIKE TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND
OUR SPONSORS AT CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO END DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FURTHER ADVOCACY ON
THIS ISSUE. TEEN DATING VIOLENCE
, ALSO KNOWN AS DATING ABUSE IS
A SERIOUS AND GROWING PROBLEM
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA, ACCORDING
TO THE ONE IN THREE ADOLESCENTS
REPORT VERBAL, EMOTIONAL,
PHYSICAL OR SEXUAL DATING ABUSE
EVERY YEAR. AS A SCHOOL TEACHER.
I SEE THE CONSEQUENCES OF THAT
ABUSE TO PARENTS. I OFTEN PLEAD
WITH. YOU ALWAYS ASK YOUR CHILD.
UH, IF THERE BEING NOT JUST
PHYSICALLY ASSAULTED OR ABUSED,
BUT ALSO ASKED, ARE YOU BEING
COERCED? AND THAT MEANS ARE YOU
BEING ASKED TO DO SOMETHING THAT
YOU DON'T WANNA DO? UH, WHETHER
IT MEANS, UH HOW YOU DRESS NOT
HANGING OUT WITH FRIENDS, UH,
NOT TELLING THE TRUTH AND OTHER
THINGS THAT CAN BE HARMFUL.
THESE ARE USUALLY PRECURSORS TO
THE ACTUAL PHYSICAL VIOLENCE,
AND WE MUST SUPPORT OUR YOUTH
AND EDUCATE THEM ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS. WE ALSO MUST
UPLIFT THOSE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED VIOLENCE AND BE
SENSITIVE TO THEIR NEEDS SO THAT
THEY ALSO MAY HEAL AND MOVE
FORWARD AS LEGISLATORS. WE HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
OUR YOUTH KNOW THE NECESSARY
SKILLS TO HAVE SAFE AND HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIPS. THIS RESOLUTION
WILL ENCOURAGE ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO OBSERVE TEEN DATING, VIOLENCE
, AWARENESS AND PREVENTION MONTH
WITH INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
PROGRAMS LIKE THE SAFE DATES
PROJECT, AS WELL AS ACTIVITIES
IN SCHOOL AND WORKSHOPS THAT RE
AWARENESS ABOUT TEEN DATING
VIOLENCE. AND WITH THAT MEMBERS
I ASKED FOR AN I VOTE ON S¼ R 60
THREE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCRETION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE HEARING IN XAN SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USE ANY UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM? HERE IN X  N. I 33 NÓ
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. B
MEMBERS WERE RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. THIS IS
A TIME FOR A JOURNEY OF
MEMORIES. WE HAVE SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. UH,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE TODAY I RISE TRÊN IN THE
MEMORY OF DEANNA CORONADO ROBLES
, A CITY BOARD MEMBER OF THE
BALL PARK. UH, UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHO PASSED AWAY LAST
NIGHT, DECEMBER 19TH AT THE AGE
OF 53. AS A LONGTIME RESIDENT OF
BALL PARK, DIANA HERSELF
GRADUATED FROM THE BALL AND PARK
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE
SHE SERVED FOR MANY YEARS. DIANA
CAR DEEPLY ABOUT THE EDUCATION
OF CHILDREN, AND SHE WAS
ESPECIALLY PASSIONATE AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS. DEANNA HELD
SEVERAL EDUCATION DEGREES AND
WAS A COMMUNITY BUSINESS OWNER
PROVIDING CHILDCARE SERVICES FOR
OVER 16 YEARS. SHE ALSO SERVED
WITH MANY COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS, INCLUDING THE
BLAND PARK NATIONAL LITTLE
LEAGUE BALL PARK. RECREATION
COMMISSION AND ALSO, UH,
PARTICIPATED IN THE CHALLENGERS
BASEBALL TEAM. SHE HAD A SPECIAL
NEEDS CHILD HERSELF, AND THAT
BECAME HER MISSION AS SHE MOVED
FORWARD AS A VERY DEDICATED, UH,
CIVIC ENGAGED PARENT ALWAYS
FIGHTING FOR CHILDREN THAT
COULDN'T FIGHT FOR THEMSELVES
AND THAT EVENTUALLY LED TO HER
WANTING TO BE ON THE SCHOOL
BOARD AND ONCE AGAIN AS SHE SAT
AS A CITY MEMBER OF THE BALL AND
PARK UNION FIVE SCHOOL DISTRICT,
SHE BECAME THE VOICE TO ALL
THOSE PARENTS WITH CHILDREN.
YOUR NEEDS. SHE WAS A WIFE FOR
34 YEARS AND LEAVES BEHIND FOUR
AMAZING CHILDREN. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN ADJOINING IN THE MEMORY OF
DEANNA CORONADO ROBLES, WHO IS A
CITY MEMBER OF THE BALL PARK.
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES. WE HAVE SAID YOU
BRING THE NAME FORWARD SO SHE
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
EXCEPT WITH SENATOR MIN. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A GIANT
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND LOS ANGELES
LABOR AND DEMOCRATIC POLITICS
WHO RECENTLY PASSED AWAY, UH, MR
RAY CORDOVA. RAY'S LIFE WAS
DEDICATED TO HIS FAMILY, HIS
COUNTRY. AND THE PURSUIT OF
PUSHING FOR ORGANIZED LABOR TO
ACHIEVE JUSTICE AND EQUITY. BORN
IN SPRINGER, NEW MEXICO AND A
PROUD GRADUATE OF THE SAINT
JOSEPH CATHOLIC HIGH SCHOOL IN
DENVER, COLORADO ROYCE ACADEMIC
JOURNEY LED HIM TO EARN A
BACHELOR'S AND A MASTER'S DEGREE
IN BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION FROM
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY LONG BEACH.
HIS EARLY COMMITMENT TO SERVICE
WAS MARKED BY HIS ENLISTMENT IN
THE U S¼ ARMY AIRBORNE, WHERE HE
SERVED AS A SERGEANT DURING THE
VIETNAM WAR. SERVICE TO OUR
NATION, SET THE STAGE FOR A LIFE
CHARACTERIZED BY HONOR, COURAGE
AND AN UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO
THE PRINCIPLES OF DEMOCRACY AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE. THE 19 SIXTIES
ON RAY WAS A LEADER WITHIN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LABOR AND
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT. BECOMING
A PRESIDENT, A MEMBER OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA LOCAL 9571 AND THEN
SERVING AS ITS VICE PRESIDENT.
HIS LEADERSHIP WOULD CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE AS HE SERVED FOR OVER 50
YEARS AS A DELEGATE WITH THE L,
A COUNTY FEDERATION OF LABOR,
ORANGE COUNTY CENTRAL LABOR
COUNCIL AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
FEDERATION OF LABOR. RAISE
ACTIVISM WAS NOT CONFINED TO
LABOR. HE WAS A LIFELONG MEMBER
OF THE  N AA èC P. A PROUD
MEMBER OF LULAC AND DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO THE LABOR COUNCIL
FOR LATIN AMERICAN ADVANCEMENT.
IN ADDITION, HE HAD MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT DURING THE
FREEDOM SUMMER OF THE 19
SIXTIES. RAL. RALPH RAY ALSO
SERVED THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WORKING FOR STATE SENATOR RALPH
èC DILLS IS A SENIOR DEPUTY
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION MEMBER
JOHN CHEN CHEN AS A AN ASSISTANT
AND CONGRESSWOMAN GRACE
NAPOLITANO AS HER DISTRICT
DIRECTOR. TO SAY THAT RAY WAS A
TITAN OF LABOR AND DEMOCRATIC
POLITICS IN ORANGE COUNTY AND L
A BARELY SCRATCHES THE SURFACE
OF HIS IMPACT. HIS ACTIVISM,
CAMPAIGNING AND MENTORING HAVE
LED AN INDELIBLE MARK ON THE
FABRIC OF OUR STATE AND THE
HEART OF A DEMOCRATIC PARTY. HE
WAS A MENTOR TO ME, AND I KNOW
PROBABLY MANY OTHERS IN THIS
ROOM. HIS UNWAVERING BELIEF IN
DEMOCRATIC VALUES AND THE
COMMITMENT TO INSTILLING THOSE
IDEALS AND OTHERS HAVE FOSTERED
A LEGACY THAT WILL ENDURE FOR
GENERATIONS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT RAY DIDN'T JUST HAVE A
LOVE FOR ORGANIZED LABOR AND
POLITICS, IS MARRIED TO HIS WIFE
SOON. CORDOVA SPANS 64 YEARS AND
WAS A CORNERSTONE OF HIS LIFE.
AS YOU REMEMBER, RAY, LET US
CARRY FORWARD THE COMMITMENT HE
DEMONSTRATED IN EVERYTHING HE
DID, AND HONOR HIS MEMORY
THROUGH OUR ACTIONS AND BY
CONTINUING TO FIGHT FOR THE
VALUES HE HELD DEAR AND THE
CAUSES HE CHAMPIONED. AS RAY
LIKED TO SAY CORDOVA'S LAW IS
THIS. IF YOU AGREE WITH ME AT
ALL TIMES, ONE OF US IS NOT
NECESSARY. HIS BELOVED WIFE,
SUN, HIS FAMILY AND HIS MANY,
MANY FRIENDS. OUR HEARTS ARE
WITH YOU IN THIS TIME OF MORNING
AND I ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME IN
ADJOURNING IN MEMORY OF RAY
CORDOVA. THANK YOU, SENATOR
UMBERG. UM THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES I. I JOIN
MY COLLEAGUE FROM IRVINE IN
HONORING RE CORDOVA RAY WAS A
FRIEND. A FRIEND OF OVER THREE
DECADES, UH, IN A LEADER, A
LEADER IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF OUR LIVES. RAY WAS
EVERYWHERE WHETHER IT WAS A
UNION EVENT, WHETHER IT WAS A
PARTY EVENT, WHETHER IT WAS A
PHILANTHROPIC EVENT. RAY WAS
THERE AND RAY WAS THERE,
ORGANIZING RAY WAS SOMEONE WHO
WAS THE FABRIC OF OUR COMMUNITY,
AND HE WILL BE DEARLY MISSED BY
ALL OF US, UM, SPECIAL
CONDOLENCES TO SUN YI, HIS WIFE,
WHO, UH, GAVE SO MUCH OF HER
FAMILY AND HERSELF TO ALL OF US,
UH, RAY WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR
MANY, MANY DECADES IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND L A COUNTY UM, THANK
YOU, RAY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
NEWMAN. UH, THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO
ADD MY VOICE TO, UH, HONORING
THE MEMORY OF RED CORDOVA. RAY
TRULY WAS A GIANT. UH IN OUR
AREA, UH, AND HIS PRESENCE WAS
ALWAYS FELT AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE FELT AS WE HONOR HIS LEGACY.
AND I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN HIS
MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
Dð RAZO. I. I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF A JOURNEYING AND
MEMORY OF BROTHER RAY CORDOVA.
UM IN MY EXPERIENCE IN THE LABOR
MOVEMENT, THERE WAS NEVER A TIME
WHEN HE WASN'T THERE, HELPING IN
SOLIDARITY WITH ANYONE'S ISSUES.
HE WAS A PROUD VETERAN. UM AND I
SAY ON BEHALF OF, UH, THE LATINO
CAUCUS AS WELL. IT WAS HE WAS
PROUD TO BE A LATINO. UM, WHO
DID ALL OF THOSE THINGS. HE
WORKED. WHEN HE COULD NOT
PHYSICALLY JUST BARELY GET
AROUND. HE WAS THERE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. HE WAS THERE DOING
FOOD DISTRIBUTIONS, UM AND
EVERYONE WHO VISITED HIM. HE
ALWAYS ALWAYS HAD THE STRENGTH
TO BE ABLE TO SAY, KEEP ON
MOVING. KEEP ON DOING WHAT
YOU'RE DOING AND NEVER GIVE UP.
HE WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
EXTRAORDINARY HUMAN BEING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. I TOO RISE. IN
RECOGNITION AND MEMORY OF RER
DOVA. THE FELLOW PARATROOPER, HE
SERVED WITH THE 101ST AIRBORNE.
I'VE OFTEN MENTIONED OVER THE
YEARS THE SACRIFICES OF OUR MEN
AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM. RAY WAS A
PARATROOPER, 100 AND FIRST, VERY
PROUD. AND I HAD THE HONOR TO
VISIT HIM. IN HIS HOSPITAL, TAKE
PICTURES AND EACH TIME I WENT TO
VISIT HIM. UH HE SEEMED TO BE
STRONGER AND STRONGER. BUT IT
WAS ONLY HIS SPIRIT AND HIS
LAUGHTER AND OBVIOUSLY HIS HIS
JOY TO SEE A FELLOW PARATROOPER
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THE TIMES WE
WERE IN AIRBORNE. WE TALKED
ABOUT THE TIMES THAT WE WERE IN
COMBAT. WE TALKED ABOUT FAMILY
AND HE TALKED ABOUT THE UNION.
HE TALKED ABOUT ALL THE FRIENDS
THAT YOU'VE MADE OVER THE YEARS
AND ESPECIALLY GRACE NAPOLITANO,
THE CONGRESSWOMAN THAT HE WORKED
FOR BUT HE ALSO TALKED ABOUT THE
LOVE OF GOD AND COUNTRY. AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT HE ASKED ME
FOR SEVERAL TIMES AND I AND I
SNUCK IT IN IS WHAT WE CALL PAN
DULCE MEXICAN BREAD AND, UH, HE
SAID, DON'T LET THE NURSES SEE
YOU BRING IT IN. AND I SAID NOT
TO WORRY. AND UH HE HAD A
SPECIAL MEXICAN BREAD AND I WAS
ABLE TO BRING THAT WE SHARED
THAT TOGETHER, SO WE WERE ABLE
TO TALK AND LAUGH. AND I KNEW
THAT, UH, EACH TIME HE WAS
GETTING A LITTLE SAT HER AND
MAYBE A LITTLE WORSE. AND UH, IT
WAS TOUGH TO SEE HIM GO, BUT, UH
, I KNOW THAT HE WILL ALWAYS BE
WITH US IN SPIRIT, UH, AS A
VETERAN AS A LABOR LEADER AND
SPECIALIST IN AMERICAN AND MAY
HE REST IN PEACE. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU. I YES,
VERY CORDOVA WAS AN AMAZING
INDIVIDUAL, AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN
AS THE GODFATHER OF LABOR
THROUGHOUT L, A IN ORANGE COUNTY
. WE ASK THAT YOU BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. THANK YOU. IF
THERE'S NÓ OTHER BUSINESS,
SENATOR MCGUIRE THE JUSTICE
CLEAR THANK YOU SO MUCH. MR
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS ENJOY YOUR
FAMILY THIS WEEK AND ENJOY
WORKING IN THE DISTRICT. THE
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED
FOR TUESDAY. FEBRUARY 20TH 2024
AT 2 P.M. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL 5 P.M.
TODAY AT WHICH TIME AN
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACED. WE'LL RECONVENE ON
TUESDAY, FEBRUARY 20TH AT 2 P.M.
AND JUST A FRIENDLY REMINDER.
TODAY IS THE LAST DAY TO
INTRODUCE BILLS THE DESK WILL BE
OPEN AGAIN UNTIL 5 P.M. THANK
YOU.